[Música]
tiene un pasado marcado por el prejuicio
pero también tiene un futuro luminoso
por delante esta mujer trans y negra
acaba de firmar un contrato con uno de
los mejores hoteles de Copacabana para
crear su carta de cócteles
son cosas que nunca imaginé para mí
porque mi vida era un gueto y un
submundo tener un hotel como este que me
ofrece la oportunidad de mostrar que soy
capaz de presentar mi trabajo a personas
diversas me engrandece de una forma tal
que solo pienso que quiero más mucho más
Desde hace 14 años Brasil mantiene el
récord de ser el país con el mayor
número de homicidios de personas trans
del mundo iniciativas como esta
contribuyen a aumentar la integración de
este colectivo en Brasil sólo el 14% de
los trans y travestis consiguen un
empleo formal el 90% tuvo que recurrir a
la prostitución como única forma de
subsistencia en algún momento de su vida
tenemos muchas iniciativas y muchas
actividades notamos mucha más aceptación
que rechazo nuestra política de
inclusión dura todo el año y no solo en
el mes del orgullo lgbti
el caso de josely resume el esfuerzo de
este colectivo para eliminar barreras
ella se formó en la universidad Federal
de Río de Janeiro donde existe un
programa pionero para formar una nueva
generación de profesionales trans para
el sector de la hostelería
desde 2019 50 alumnos han pasado por
trans garzón 20 han encontrado trabajo
en este campo trans garzón es el único
curso de Brasil especializado en la
formación de personas trans mantenemos
un banco de currículum destinados a
empresas que colaboran con nosotros y
que tienen interés en trabajar con la
inclusión y la diversidad históricamente
la discriminación expulsa los trans de
las escuelas este proyecto intenta
garantizar el acceso y la permanencia de
esas personas en el mundo del trabajo